All right. So, uh, so Emily,
this is your first book. It is,
you didn't want to start with something
simpler, a brief history of time maybe.
I mean, I know that's been
done, but, um, but, but uh,
as you write in the book,
He,
and this is the most complicated robot
ever sent to another planet, in fact,
ever sent off earth. Why did you, why
did you want to write about this and,
and why do you say that it's
the most complicated? Oh,
I think it's fair to admit that I didn't
realize what I was getting into when I
started writing this book. In fact, as
I, as I explained in the introduction,
it's not actually the book that I
meant to write to begin with. It's, uh,
I was approached by Springer to write
a book about the curiosity mission.
And I wrote,
and I wrote and I wrote and I
wasn't finishing and I couldn't,
I wound up with a tremendous quantity of
material and it wasn't able to wrap it
up. And I finally figured out that the
reason I was having so much trouble it was
because I'd accidentally
written two books.
And so this is actually just the
first of a pair of books on curiosity.
The second one is going to be coming out
next year and will be about the science
mission.
So I kind of was able to partition the
engineering stuff into one book and
science to another book.
And basically this is the book that I
needed in order to be able to understand
the rover well enough to be able
to write about it. Science mission.
And so now I'm writing about the science.
I'm actually,
I've got a copy on my desk and I
keep on referring to it all the time.
How many of this thing does it have and
how long did it and when did this fail?
And it's all in there. Um, so, so,
so tell us a little more about
why it is the most, what,
what makes it the most complicated robot
we've ever sent off this planet? It's a,
it's sort of the culmination of a long
history of NASA is exploration of Mars.
And, um, I think that the key to
its complexity is that as you,
um, NASA builds on from one mission to
the next, you begin with a very basic,
broad set of questions.
What is Mars?
And you map it and you find out some
more things about what it is and then you
ask more detailed questions.
Was water ever important on Mars?
And spirit and opportunity were sent
with this mantra, follow the water,
try to understand how mark,
uh, water was active on Mars.
And the past curiosities questions
are more subtle than that.
We know that there was water on Mars,
but did they ever have a
habitable environment that, um,
Mike organisms might have
been able to live in?
And so as the questions get subtler,
the investigations that you have to do
to try to answer those questions get more
detailed, more complicated. Um, it's not
enough just to snap pictures anymore.
You have to have much more
detailed kinds of data.
And curiosity has these
two highly sophisticated
laboratory instruments that are
designed to ingest solid samples and
perform x Ray diffraction and ex-ray a
fluorescence feet performs
gas chromatograph mass
spectrometry with a tuneable
laser spectrometer at a
quadrupole mass spectrometer.
It's kind of like all of these
laboratory instruments that have been
miniaturized to fit inside the rover.
And so just supporting that
hardware requires a host of,
of subsystems that are necessary
to keep the thing alive.
You also have to have a mission
that lasts a lot longer.
The warranty on spirit and
opportunity is famously only 90 days.
And of course opportunity is still
going after 5,000 and something Saul's,
do you know off the top of your head?
Huh?
Uh, let me check my Mars time
APP. Why it's 5,107 Saul's today,
Emily.
All right, very good. So yeah, curiosity
has not lasted nearly so long yet.
Um,
and in fact it's quite likely that
curiosity will not last as many sauces as
opportunity does. It's almost
certain. Um, but anyway,
the point is that that the opportunity
was only warranted to last 90 days.
It was supposed to be able to accomplish
it's prime mission in that amount of
time. Curiosities, warranty
ran out after a first year.
And so you have to build a much more
robust systems. First Martian, yeah,
first Martian year. Yes,
that's correct. Um, uh,
you have to build much more robust
systems to be able to support all of that.
And so that also made it more complex
because you have a lot of redundancy and
other things built in
to make it last so long.
Famously, the one of those two
labs you were talking about, the,
the sample analysis at Mars
or Sam Instrument, um, I
think it was rich, Rick Welsh,
you pointed out that that instrument
alone is larger than the entire chassis of
the Mars exploration rovers.
That's right. Yeah. And it's
big. It's heavier than the
sojourner rover was. I mean,
it's the size of a
microwave, which, you know,
in Earth terms for laboratory instrument,
it's amazingly miniature.
But in terms of what a mobile rover has
to support on the surface of another
planet,
it's enormous and has high power demands.
It has exacting temperature
requirements and it's just,
it's a very complicated
piece of machinery.
I think that might be the size of the
entire first rover that we said. Yeah,
sojourner, it's what Sam is the size of
sojourner, bigger than the chassis of,
of the Mars exploration
rovers. Um, uh, so, uh, you,
you did an enormous amount of
research at it. It shows any,
it pays off really well in
this book. This, by the way,
is the first technically,
or I've run a lot of tech or technically
oriented books in my life and this is
the first technically oriented book that
I've read that uses terms like stubborn
gunk. I think it does a very
good job of kind of like making,
making these very complicated things
accessible to a lay audience. Um,
uh, and that's kind of an
outgrowth of the work that you do.
You are the senior planetary,
a senior editor and planetary
evangelists at the planetary society.
Do you see this as kind of
an outgrowth of that? Right?
Oh, absolutely. Yeah. So yeah. So, ah,
I see what I do at the planetary society
as kind of a translation function.
There's so many exciting things happening
in science and engineering and space
exploration right now. Um, and uh,
while I was a grad student exploring
these things, I thought, you know,
this stuff is really cool
but nobody learns about it.
And one of the main reasons that
nobody learns about is that the,
the ways that scientists and engineers
communicate with each other are really
frankly kind of horrible. Science
papers are just bad. They're,
they're boringly written. Um,
they're difficult to understand.
But when you train as a
scientist or engineer,
you learn that language and you become
capable of reading it and understanding
it.
And um,
you learn to use a whole new vocabulary
of terms that have very specific and
precise meanings.
But when you use that same language
to speak to a member of the public,
you are basically speaking a language
that's foreign to that member of the
public. So you have to
translate. And it's not,
one of the phrases that I hate the most
in public communication is dumbing down
because you are not a,
you're not making things stupider.
You are translating to a language that
you can use to communicate with other
people. And so it's perfectly
possible to get across, um,
complicated concepts. You just have to
use the words that people can understand.
So when I need to write
about stubborn gunk,
I write about stubborn gunk because
that's exactly what we're talking about.
We're talking about material
that is sticking to the
sides of an instrument that
you can't get off even by shaking
it. And that's, that's what, uh,
the Phoenix lander was dealing with in
the section that I wrote that about.
And it, you know, you've all dealt with
that problem in your own homes and lives.
I'm quite sure. And, and it's just, it's
better to write about it in that way.
It's more exciting. It is just as
effective at communicating as saying,
I dunno, high viscosity material, um,
that has adsorbed onto the walls of the
sample collection device or something
like that. You know, you could say
it that way, but why? I wonder if it,
instead of dumbing down, we can say
that this is a smarting down the rover,
just a translation.
It's a translation of,
of how everything works to make it more
accessible to uh, uh, to the speakers of,
uh, to, uh, to people who are non native
speakers of science. Right. And you're,
and you're well positioned to do that
having trained as a scientist yourself.
That's, that's also your
background. Yeah. Yes, yes.
I'm a planetary geologist
by training, so I as an, um,
as an Undergrad I did feel geology.
I got to walk around on mountains and
whack things with rock hammers and draw a
pencil and colored a colored
pencil maps and things.
And then in Grad school I studied geology
on Venus using radar images from the
Magellan orbiter, which is just, it's such
an underappreciated mission. It's, um,
it ended in the early nineties.
It mapped all of Venus in,
in radar wave lengths. And Venus has
a fascinating looking planet and like,
I really wish now, so I would get
a mission back there sometime soon.
But it's hard.
It's hard to study because of the insanely
high temperatures and the sulfuric
acid clouds and the temperature.
The pressure at the surface is the same.
Is that a mile beneath the ocean?
So it's tough to build hardware that
survives for very long on Venus. Yeah.
I wouldn't want to be the guy who tries
to design the rover that can rove around
where temperatures will melt. We'll land.
Yes. It doesn't seem like fun. Yeah.
Solder is not gonna work.
Right.
And the Russians succeeded in exploring
the surface of Venus by essentially
building a,
I mean it's an exaggeration,
but they were basically
clockwork spacecraft. I mean,
they were mechanical. Yeah.
Craft. Because you can build mechanical
components that can work at very high
temperatures.
Electronics,
especially in the 1970s we're not ready
to operate at those kinds of conditions.
And the Russians being the Russians
built these big robust spacecraft that
basically worked with these mechanical
systems and we're able to take
measurements after on the surface for
a matter of minutes to an hour or so
before the spacecraft failed.
And that's how we know anything
about the surface of Venus.
Um, so, uh, so, so we're turning
our attention to Mars. Um,
one of the things I think you do really
well in this book, um, uh, which,
which I greatly enjoyed
reading and enthusiastically
recommend by the way. Um, uh,
one of the things I think you really,
really do well in this book is you, you,
you don't just translate all of the
technical jargon and terms that people can
understand, but you also recognize,
and this is again, part of your,
your work at the planetary
society. I think, um,
that you can't talk about
this rover just as a machine.
It's not just at the rover is a machine.
It's that the rover like carries with
it a lot of human hopes and ambitions.
And I think you've kind of communicate
that as well as is what we're,
we're hoping and dreaming to
explore on surface of Mars.
Yeah. There's a, um,
there's a book that was written actually
by a sociologist by the name Jennifer
TC,
who has embedded with several of NASA,
has a jps operations
teams on space missions.
And she studies the sociology of how teams
work when they work on these missions.
And one of the most striking things that
she observed that really made me sit
back and go, Huh, is the
the Pronoun that um, uh,
that JPL engineers and scientists use
when they refer to the rover. You know,
it's sometimes, uh, some people do say it,
it can be traditional to call ships of
exploration. She like, you know, uh,
ocean going ships are often
referred to as she, but that's,
it's not actually very common to
use that Pronoun for curiosity.
The most common pronoun is we. And so
think about that for a, for a minute.
What it means to be referring
to this machine as we,
it means that we are exploring Mars.
We drilled today,
we are driving across that hill.
It's, it's not just one machine,
it's the embodiment of all of the people
participating together on this mission.
And it's,
it's such a team thing,
especially because of the way that there
were all these operational roles on the
mission and many different people who
can fill those operational roles on any,
on any given day. So it
feels more like, um, I dunno,
I feel it feels kind of
like, uh, um, uh, being on a,
on a ship on the ocean in a
way where there is a captain,
but there's all these other commanders
and everything else and every person has
their part to contribute to make it going.
And together you're on this
great ship of exploration.
That's what curiosity fuels like.
And so it,
it kind of feels like there's a false
dichotomy between human and robotic
exploration because this is
human exploration, right?
We are seeing the surface of Mars.
We're exploring places that humans could
never go, or at least not now. And, uh,
we're doing it through the eyes of robots.
And I think that, um, you know, as,
as virtual reality gets more commonplace
as we decreased the separation between
humans and the machines and
the software that we use,
we're actually going to see a merging of
human and robotic exploration where we
may have human exploration
of the surface of Venus,
except that it will be humans and an
orbiting spacecraft using robotic avatar
has to explore the surface. And it
sound science. Fictiony but it's not,
it's really not that farfetched given
current technology and would be a much
more efficient way for us to
get human brains into surf,
into rope,
into environments that are really hard to,
for humans to survive. Terrible
radiation environment's terrible heat,
a crushing pressure. Um, you
know, all of those things.
We just put robot bodies
down there and we'd say,
if we can manage to use our human
brains effectively, then, then that's,
I think the future of exploration.
Right. And then you haven't
gone down into the gravity well,
and so you don't have to get the people
boosted back off the post so that you
can land the humans on Phobos or
something and having, you know,
telling operating a mission
on the surface below them.
Yeah. It turns out to be harder to do.
Aereo synchronis orbits, that's Mars.
Geosynchronous orbits the earth.
Geosynchronous orbits because Maurice has
gravity fueled is a lot lumpier and so
it's hard to keep you to do station
keeping with your spacecraft to keep it
positioned over the one, um,
at over a single spot on Mars.
But there are like two stable positions.
Um,
in longitude or met a stable position.
So you have to like really want to
explore the part of Mars that's underneath
those two table positions.
Yeah.
So you were talking about the way that,
um, that we embody the rover, right? That,
that we are the rover and the,
the, the language that's used.
But another thing that, uh, Janet
for Tessie pointed out was that,
that in the same way as
we embody the rover, uh,
we also use our bodies to communicate
about the rover. And so like for example,
with spirit and opportunity,
we'll talk about the solar panels.
By you bend your body forward,
you splay your arms backward in this
position because that's what the solar
panels look like. That's when
you talk about the solar panels.
You do that when you talk
about the mobility system,
you kind of move your arms in
this characteristic way, right?
And steer the wheels like
this. Um, and, and you,
when you talk about the robotic arm,
you,
you use your arm and it's always the
left arm because their left arm. Um, uh,
did you find yourself doing that
when you're writing this book?
Did you kind of inhabit the rover,
the rover, his body that way?
I did that a little bit,
but I actually find myself doing it a
lot less with curiosity than I do with
spirit and opportunity. Everybody
else does too. Yeah. So spirit,
spirit and opportunity, you have this, um,
they're much more human scale
and there's some metrical,
it's much more easy to imagine them has
having the body plan of a person or a
donkey or a dog or whatever you want
to imagine it. Curiosity is, um,
it's, uh, you know, it's not nearly as
symmetrical. It's not nearly as pretty.
And,
and to be honest,
I really didn't like the appearance of
curiosity when I first started doing the
research on this book. I
often feel like, you know,
there's these three generations
of rovers. There's, um, a store,
sojourner spirit and
opportunity and curiosity.
And I feel like sojourner was sort of a
loyal little dog that it couldn't ever
go any farther out of sight of the
lander because it didn't have its own
communication skills.
So it just kind of poked around a rock.
So you could even see these images of it,
like lifting his leg on a rock because
it like drives up and it kept driving and
it,
and there's actually an image of the rover
like perched right almost sideways on
a rock like this. Um, and then spirit and
are much more surefooted. They're bigger,
they're more human scale. So I, in
my extended animal metaphor there,
the boroughs that used to,
or the donkeys,
it used to accompany the
western geologists as they
explore the geology and in
the American West. And then so what
does that make curiosity? Well,
it's the animal design by committee.
It's a camel to ship of the desert.
It moves slowly and steadily across
the desert landscape, you know,
carrying its load, lumbering
load with it. And, uh,
and that's what curiosity is like.
And like I said,
I didn't really love it when I first saw
the design, but that change actually,
um, the JPL had a moment, um,
had an opportunity for the media to come
into the clean room and see curiosity
before it got shipped
to Florida for launch.
And so I was actually able to put on
all the, they call it a bunny suit,
the white suit and the cap and everything
else and go in and see curiosity,
fate face to face.
And I have to say that I kind of fell
in love with curiosity when I had the
opportunity to sit there and a, and
meet it face to face. But yeah, I don't,
I don't feel like I embody curiosity
nearly as much because it's,
it's so ungainly it's a different
kind of creature from a spirit,
an opportunity.
And,
and that,
that seems to be kind of widespread
on the product to Washington facade.
I talks about, about data,
about how people have, have,
he feels like people have emotionally
connected with curiosity less than with
spirit and opportunity.
Um,
I think also it's a,
it may partly be because of the way
that the spirit and opportunity are much
more, um, uh, responsive in a way.
They, you come in on a morning,
you plan the day and then that's it.
Whereas curiosity has to be planned by
committees as well, where you have, um,
act as many as four parallel planning
processes that are happening at the same
time operating on different timescales.
You do have a tactical operations team
that is planning everyday of operations,
but then there's a look ahead planning
team that is planning a couple of days of
operations.
There's a longterm planning team that's
looking at months and then there's a
project science group that is kind
of keeping track of all of the,
the mission requirements and um,
unlike spirit and opportunity,
most of the decisions for curiosity
get made many more days in advance.
So it's, it's much less
responsive. So it feels in a way,
a lot more like some of the other big
NASA missions like Cassini or these other
things that need to be planned
in much longer in advance.
Yeah, that's, it's, it's kind
of this weird hybrid, right,
where we're for that and for also for
project management reasons because it has
like lots of pis for the different
instruments instead of one pie overseeing
them all as on spirit opportunity.
And so there's,
there's this kind of council of,
of monarchs
kind of content council of elders.
Yeah. It's, it's all men by the way,
which I hate really bad. So
there's this group of like 12, um,
pis and they're all men. There's a lot
of awesome women working on this team.
But yeah,
a lot of great engineers working on a team
and I'm working on operations as well.
Um, and in fact, that was
one of the things I was going
to ask you about was, um,
uh, you know, you, you cite some of those
women in the book. Um, some of them,
the woman who designed the soft spot,
for example,
of the sample acquisition at
handling system. Um, are you
hoping that, uh, you know,
as, as, as,
as you are well known for your kind of
science outreach or also well known as
being an advocate of women in science
and engineering? And Are you hoping that,
you know,
one of the many effects of this book
will be to encourage women to go into
science and engineering to see
if there's a role for them?
I don't see it work. I
don't think that that's, uh,
something that I see coming as an outcome
of this book. I think the book is,
you know, designed to feed
people's insatiable curiosity
about what curiosity is.
Right. Um, and honestly, you know,
as a parent of two daughters,
I don't see any problems with the number
of women who want to go into science
edition. Yeah, sure. It's weather science
and engineering wants to keep them there.
Really.
Ultimately it's,
these missions are really hard because
they operate when you first land on Mars,
the amount of time you spend,
um,
just continuous hours working
on these missions. It's just,
it's kind of nightmarish
and I don't really go into
that that much in this book.
If you're interested in books were kind
of the life of being on a mission is
central.
You can read,
there's another recently published book
by Alan Stern and David Grinspoon called
chasing new horizons. It's about
the new horizons mission to Pluto.
And at every stage of that mission,
it was like we thought
we were rolling before,
but we had to get even more all in.
And then I just started working 16 hours
a day and getting by on three hours of
sleep. And it's like the four Yorkshire
men sketch right from money python.
It just keeps on getting worse and worse.
And You wonder how people
can last like this.
And people with families can't last
like that for very long, you know?
So you have primarily young
people working on missions, um,
at least on tactical operations.
It's just,
it's difficult now over
time on a mission like this,
they did what they were able to
change the operational structure.
So first after about,
um,
after 90 days they went off of Mars time.
Um,
so Mars time is where you set your
clock to the rotational rate of Mars,
which has days, 40 minutes longer
than earth days. And Scott,
you're always my example of the Weirdo
who loves Mars time because like if you
are a person who's like a
night owl with no children,
you have children now of course.
But if you are a night owl
with no children and you
love to sleep in what's not
to love about sleeping in 40 minutes
later every day and it sounds great,
but like if you have any connection
with the rest of humanity as totally
miserable,
if you have children who have,
or a spouse or partner who has,
who wants to like see you
during ordinary daylight hours,
it's absolutely miserable. It's
also kind of dangerous. You know,
I was on Mars time,
um,
with spirit and opportunity for a little
while and because the schedule slips
around the clock, you wind
up, I'm sleep deprived,
driving home after being up all night
during morning rush hour or an empty
highways and you fall asleep while
driving and get into a wreck.
And Steve Squyres has actually really
concerned about this and did all kinds of
training for the operations team
before the mission started. But anyway,
after 90 days they knew this mission
was a marathon, not a sprint.
They quickly went off of Mars time.
Um,
after 180 days they stopped
working on Sundays. Um,
after another 90 days they
stopped working on Saturdays.
And what that means is that it
really builds up your Friday,
you have to produce a three sol plan,
a three day plan on a Friday.
And sometimes it means that you're not
taking advantage of the full capability
of the rover. But they did do, um,
they do clever things like
some of these instruments,
like the Sam Instrument has to cook
samples in an oven that is tremendously
power demanding.
So you might say cook them in an oven on
a Saturday and just take Sunday off to
let the batteries recharged because
the rover would have to do that anyway.
So you might as well do it at a time
when you don't want to double up on your
planning.
And so over time they have actually
managed to get the operations requirement
down to about nine hours a day.
It's still a little bit long workday,
they still do kind of play
with a calendar a bit.
So sometimes you have to
come in and work at like six,
7:00 AM because that's when you need to
get the commands up to the rover before
2:00 PM or whatever it is. Sometimes you
have to come in late, but they still,
now they allow everybody to have a good
night's sleep except for the poor Kim
Kam team. Kim Kam is one of the
instruments and it's operated from France.
So now that they're on earth time,
um,
the poor Kim Cam team primarily
works overnight and it's
kind of misery for them,
but they trade off. There's only, they
work into operational roles over time.
Like they might have two days on ops
per week and then the rest of the week
they're not an option and they
don't have to do that schedule.
And so I find that as these missions
go on, you'll find a lot of,
I'm older, I'm a lot more women of
people coming into operations cause the,
the what the work time is
much more predictable and
it's much easier to balance
it with all the other obligations
you may have in your daily life.
So do you, you're appointed about families
on Mars time. You'll remember that, uh,
when uh, curiosity landed, there was
an engineer, David Oh. Um, who, uh,
he and his wife and their two kids
all went on Mars time together. Um,
because the kids didn't have to be back
in school for a month or month and a
half or something like that.
And so they all just all went on Mars
time and they were all living at the whole
family was living on Mars time. What is
the first of those that I've heard of?
Yeah.
Yeah. And they had a blog about that
doesn't work for everybody all the time.
It was actually great.
They talked about what can you do
in Los Angeles with two children,
young children at midnight at,
and they found all kinds of interesting
why walks they could do with lights and
things like that was actually a pretty
cool going to the beach at like, you know,
overnight is really interesting.
And so they had a good time.
They saw lots of interest in wildlife
and they went to various all night
restaurants at the kids love. So they
actually had a good time with that.
So,
um,
so you studied all the instruments on
curiosity in excruciating detail for this
book. Um, uh, in that process,
did you come out with a favorite?
What's your favorite instrument?
Oh, I never have favorites.
Um, but she lied. But go ahead.
I do have to say that,
that Molly is pretty cool.
Molly's are really cool instruments.
So Molly stands for the Mars
Hand Lens imager. It's Maa Hli.
It's the camera that's on the
end of the robotic arm. And, um,
for reasons that I go into
exhaustive detail on in the book,
it turns out to be the widest angle camp
color camera also that the rover has.
So I can take the broadest
views and because it's on
the arm, you know, they can,
the whole point of it is to take
images of um, targets that they do.
They're in situ work on
with their instruments.
And so they'll use Molly to take an
image from about a foot away and then
they'll zoom in and take one from about
five centimeters away and then another
one from about to one
or two centimeters away.
And that gets you a nested set of images,
um,
at increasing resolution that helps
you see what's going on in the rocks.
Um, but because it's a
focus, a little camera,
it can also focus at infinity.
So you can take long distance views and
of course you can turn it back and look
at the rover. And so this is,
it's the first Mars rover, um,
to demonstrate capability of
taking a self portrait on Mars.
Although notably opportunity recently
took a self portrait on Mars.
It too has a, um, are mounted camera.
It's camera is not focused [inaudible]
so the images that it took of itself,
we're very blurry but it's
still unmistakably the rover
and it was really quite
a thrill to see that.
But yeah,
it's become part of standard operating
procedure for curiosity to take a selfie
whenever it's at a drill site.
And so we have these self portraits of
curiosity across the surface of Mars and
you can see it getting increasingly dusty.
The one that you're seeing on the screen
up here is a special one where um,
the,
the first self portrait actually that
curiosity took was just of the wheels on
the surface.
And you want to do that so that you
can check and see how the wheels are
contacting the surface check and see
the condition of the wheels after the
landing. Um, and they, uh,
you know, after they did that,
they, in order to do that they
have to have the, the arm very low,
obviously underneath the
undercarriage of the rover.
Most of the selfies are shot at an
altitude that's similar to the altitude of
the mass cam cameras. So
that they're, it's, it's you
know, taking a self portrait.
But this one, they were
actually at a drill site where
the ground slope downward,
which made life actually quite
difficult for the drill team.
But because the ground was sloping
downward away from the rover,
they were able to turn the turret
and take a full selfie from that low
perspective. So that's what gives you
this very low perspective on the rover.
And those self portraits are cool.
And the um,
some people on the science team or
on an engineering team were dubious.
But when the,
the Molly,
a principal investigator and a couple of
the workers on that mission a simulated
what it could look like and showed it
to the engineering team, they were like,
oh my God,
we have to do this.
And so like with everything they have to
do it on earth before they can do it on
Mars. And so the first selfie was
actually taken by the earth copy,
the earth twin of curiosity.
Inside.
It's a little garage in the Mars Yard
at JPL and you can see there's two
engineers in the background.
One of them is vandever event.
She's like around the corner and it's the,
um, as the camera image is being taken,
it's pretty cool. Yeah, I was a, I was,
I am surprised that you said the Molly
was your favorite because everybody,
when they,
when you asked what their favorite
instrument on the on curiosity is,
everybody always has to laser
cause Qpp people come on,
it's a rover with a fricking laser beam
on and say exactly what's not to love
about that. Exactly. And actually,
so it is kind of fun. There's,
there's very imaginative, um, artwork.
So, you know, curiosity happening,
various things.
My favorite one actually is one
that I first saw in a cam cam team.
Kim Cam is the instrument
that has a laser. Um,
they were doing a team presentation at a
science meeting and they had a photo of
curiosity shooting a laser and a full on
Michael Bay explosions happening at the
end of the laser. And you're
like, oh yeah. So no, it's um,
I just, I like pictures. What can I say?
Pictures tell a stories and I
really like the Molly pictures.
One thing Kim Kim has though is
it does have a camera on it, um,
for to take context images of where these
app with their laser and later on in
the mission they trained the camera to
be able to focus at infinity so that you
can take a long distance photos and
the Cameron has this circular baffle.
So it's the highest resolution camera
I can take the most distant photos.
So it's just like taking a spyglass and
like seeing these long distance features.
Oh boy. There's that, uh, you know,
fairly network that we were going
to visit in the future. And,
and so I always kind of feel like a
ship's captain every time I see those chem
cam pictures just with clear,
I didn't mean to disagree
with you about the Mollys.
I think it's a very strong choice. And
Molly also has a flashlight. Yes. Kim,
my wife who works on the
rovers, uh, on curiosity.
That's her favorite is the flashlight. Oh
yeah. There's actually two flashlights.
And the reason for that is because if
you're a geologist working in the field
with your Rock Hammer,
you smash off a piece of fresh rock to
look at the crystals inside and try to
identify what minerals are present you.
You'll do this with the rock sample to
try to catch a glance from the sun to see
if there's reflective surfaces and
what the angles are to each other.
While curiosity can't do that.
But what it can do is take his two
little flashlights on Molly and go blink,
blink pink, pink thing, blink to,
to do lights coming from
two different directions.
And so that's what it does to try to,
to catch a crystal glance.
I don't know that it's
ever worked that way. Um,
but they do use the flashlights at
night because that way they have a light
source of known illumination properties.
And so all the night images that they've
taken of all of their drill sites,
they can compare the color to each other
because they're all taken under exactly
the same illumination conditions.
So in addition to the, uh,
the laser on the rover,
uh,
I actually learned from your book is not
a thing that I realized before reading
your book, but I learned from
your book that Dan, the data,
the dynamic Albido of neutrons
experiment, um, has an eye on cannon. Yes.
We've got a laser and an eye on Kennedy.
All we need is a rover with a light
saber and we've got the TRIFECTA.
That's right. Yeah. Yeah. Uh, another,
another really cool thing I learned about,
uh,
the science instruments for reading
the book was, um, uh, about the Rad,
which has a scintillating
plastic detector. Yes.
Which I love that name.
I had decided that scintillating plastic
conductor as the name of my music cover
band.
Yeah. It's not, there's all kinds of, uh,
fun terms and they tend to squeeze
all of these terms into acronyms.
And so you talk about Sam's, tls and QMS
and doing gcms and all of the samples.
And, and I think it's actually a lot
more fun to say Gas Chromatograph Mass
Spectrometer. It sounds like, it sounds
like start start trekkies you know,
and let's send those, let's fire things
up in our oven and send them through the,
um, what does it, the manifolds, the,
there are many manifolds inside Sam and
you stand up with your helium carrier
gas through manifold a and send it off
to the tunable laser spectrometer and see
what that is. It's just fun. It's fun.
There's a lot of, a lot of fun terms. Uh,
um, so, uh, so again,
having studied all the instruments and
like this exhaustive detail as you say,
um, which, which of them do you think
was the most complicated instrument? Um,
of all of them on the river?
Yeah, that one's easy to answer, but
the first thing I want to answer is,
is like when he says exhaustive detail,
exhaustive is the most common
adjective you use to describe my book.
And I'm just glad that it's not
exhausting, right? Yeah. So, yeah,
so fascinating by the
exhaustive, right. So, um,
uh,
definitely without question,
the most complicated instrument
as the Sam Instrument.
So Sam means sample analysis at Mars.
It's one of two laboratory instruments.
And it's interesting that the
two laboratory instruments,
one of them is really very
simple. And that's Kevin. It's a,
that's an instrument that it has a,
um,
it has a laser that it shines through
a little sample of powder and it,
it shakes the powder so
that those crystals all toss
around in various different
orientations. And the crystal scatter
the light and you get a diffraction plot.
It's the same kind of technology that
I'm Rosalind Franklin used to figure out
the structure of DNA. You're doing x Ray
crystallography basically. And it's, um,
and that's all it is.
You take a picture of the,
of the diffraction and then you download
that picture and you can say, oh,
these minerals are present. And that's
it. And that's one of the two, um, uh,
laboratory instruments. But then
there, Sam and Sam is ridiculous.
I cannot believe they actually built
this instrument and put it on a rover on
Mars. It has, um,
it has a carousel of more
than 70 little courts cups.
It can rotate this carousel under two
different inlets to receive samples.
Then it rotates the carousel and lifts
a cup into an oven. And the oven,
it can heat things up to 500 degrees.
It can heat it in steps,
it can heat it with a ramp, it can heat
it for a little bit, then hold it or not.
It can heat it all the way.
It can heat it part way.
It can take it down and do it,
bring it back up again. Um,
and then there is a little helium tank
that takes all of the gases that come off
of the oven and sends them into one of
numerous possible different instruments.
But before that it sends them into these
little chambers called manifolds. Um,
which are, you know, a manifold is
a place where you have lots of, um,
things intersecting and by opening and
closing one of dozens of different valves,
they can send the material onto
different getters and scrubbers,
which takes certain stuff
out of, out of the, um,
the gases they can turn,
turn on to get her for a little while
and then heat the getter to release the
stuff again. And then they send that
into one of three different instruments.
So there's all these valves,
there's all these different ways
that all these knobs to turn. Um,
they actually developed a, basically
a programming language that they can,
that the SAM team can use to send
things through the Sam Instrument.
One of the wackiest things
I think is that the,
the Pi on the Sam instrument was very
proud of the fact that it's, that he can,
that he programs it had
basic, right. I was like,
I know, I know very little
about programming languages,
but I know enough to know that
that's not something to be proud of.
It's not widely used at Google. That's,
yeah, sure. So anyway, it's, um,
it's incredibly complicated and to most
people it's just a box that you, um,
that the SAM team asks for Knobs to be
turned and they turned the knobs and data
comes out.
And then even once you have the data,
you still don't have answers because,
um,
the kinds of things that they're trying
to figure out are so complex that the
only way to be sure that
you figured it out right,
is to create a sample of known composition
and put it through a duplicate of the
instrument in a lab on earth
under Martian conditions.
So that's temperature and
vacuum and it's so San results,
there's actually going to be a press
conference tomorrow concerning a science
paper that,
um,
is one of the main people on the
press panel is Paul Mahaffey,
who's the principal
investigator on this instrument.
And so I'm sure that the paper concerns
data that was taken at least six months
ago,
probably years ago,
because that's just how long it takes
to understand the results from this
instrument.
Uh,
fortunately there are other instruments
that produced much more rapid results
and make things a little more interesting
for those of us following along in the
mission.
Yeah.
So Sam instrument has another talent.
If there were a talent
show on Mars curiosity,
curiosities entry would be singing.
That's right. Sam famously
sang happy birthday to itself
using it. Sam Instrument.
I actually don't know the details of
what was vibrating or making noises.
Was it like an FPGA or something?
Hello?
I don't know the details.
My wife is the instrument engineer
for the Sam Instrument Insurance,
so she could probably tell us about
that. And again, exhausting, right
detail. Um, so, so anyway, but this story
does surface once a year. Yeah. Right. Uh,
but I am here to tell you it does not
sing happy birthday to itself every year.
That once on Mars. It was a cute little
stunt and, and that's, uh, that's it.
Okay. So, um, we've been talking for
about 40 minutes. Um, what's, uh,
what's throwing out for
audience questions as well? Um,
and kind of while we're getting,
oh, have you seen our microphone?
This is really cool.
The microphone's a little box and a
soft box and they can just throw the box
around the room. Um, but, uh, while
we're, while we're waiting for that,
let me ask you,
you,
you were saying the Sam Instrument
is the most complicated instrument.
Was it also the hardest to explain?
It was absolutely by far
the hardest to explain.
You'll find about 50 pages of
book on the Sam Instrument night.
I wore Paul Mahaffey out asking
questions about, because you know,
when I first started writing this, I
envisioned um, you know, you, you, you,
uh,
have you heat stuff up,
you get a gas and it goes through
the machine comes out and,
but that's not how it works at all. You
heat, you heat it up, you get a gas,
it goes into one place, then you open
a valve and it goes into this place.
Then you might be turning on something
that pumps slightly but not too much and
you get like a gradient going.
It's so incredibly complicated that the,
the main comment that I get from people
on the mission who are not on the Sam
team is thank God somebody's
finally explained this to
me because I have no idea
how
cool.
Uh, so I was wondering how does the delay
between earth and Mars like affect the
teams that operate the rover?
Like,
is it a lot easier to do work when
earth and Mars are close together?
Ah, so no, actually
that's a good question.
So Mars and earth have a wildly differing,
a distance to each other,
which affects the,
the communications lag.
But the fact of the matter is that
because the lag is many minutes,
regardless of the relative distances,
there's no real time commanding.
So you are always doing, um, a
full Saul worth of sequencing.
At a minimum you send the rover receives
its commands at 10:00 AM every morning,
a Mars time. And so, uh,
the reason that they do that is
because earth is always up in Mars,
has sky at 10:00 AM local time.
Earth is closer to the sun than Mars is.
So it's always somewhere
relatively close to the sun.
And so if you're doing your
commanding at 10:00 AM, um,
earth will always be up in the sky,
although sometimes it can be
a little low on the horizon.
And so the rover executes,
it's a one Saul's worth of commands.
And then in the afternoon, um, there
are overflights by to Mars orbiters,
Mars Odyssey and Mars
reconnaissance orbiter.
And it sends its data through a UHF,
a connection up to the orbiter,
which receives the data and
then relays it onto earth.
And so there's also overnight
passes by the orbiters. And so, um,
you wind up having to command in
these at minimum one Saul increments.
And so it really doesn't matter how
close Mars is except that it is,
um,
uh,
you can get much higher bandwidth and
your transmission's between Mars and earth
and Mars is closer. So you do get
more data return from the orbiter, uh,
because it can communicate faster.
You can use a higher data
rate when they're close.
And so you'll see these like seasonal
spikes and data rate that are not actually
seasonal.
They happen when Maurice
has near opposition when
earth and Mars are close to
each other. And then on
the opposite side, when,
when Mars gets into
conjunction with a song,
you actually have three weeks where
you're not allowed to talk to the rover at
all.
Cause if there were a problem you couldn't
be sure that your message would get
through on garbled to be
able to save the rover.
So they all the spacecraft kind of hunker
down and go into a fairly low activity
mode during conjunction.
I have a question.
Are there pieces of the rover
that it can separate from itself?
Like in this selfie picture?
Um,
I don't see how there's something attached
to it that would take the selfie. So,
um,
this,
the question of who took the picture and
how the Selfie works is one that pops
up every single time I post a selfie.
The issue is that the, although the,
the field of view of the
Molly camera is fairly wide,
it's not anywhere near as wide as the kind
of camera you have in your cell phone.
It's actually very narrow.
So in order to take a Selfie,
the rover actually takes about 70 pictures
of itself in kind of a matrix sort of
way. And it repositions the arm to
keep the arm out of view. You know,
it would never be able to photograph.
It's whole arm regardless.
And so you wind up mosaic
King and image together, um,
like this out of, out of multiple
different images and they just, uh,
they do it in a way so that the,
the arm is not constantly poking into
view from all these different directions
because when, um, when you do
take the Selfie, you do see,
uh,
you know,
you will see the arm in multiple images
and so you have to come up with a way of
uh,
neatly cutting it off.
You actually see more of the arm in
this picture than you see in most of the
self portraits. Usually they
chop it off at the shoulder, um,
because otherwise it would be
crossing the front of the, um, rover.
But because of all
those multiple pictures,
you wind up being able
to get the arm out of it.
And there's no real sensible way.
One of the more disconcerting images that
I've seen was a self portrait taken by
the math camp,
which is the only way that opportunity
and spirit can take self portraits.
As you take a, you can get a, um,
a mosaic of the deck of the
rover by shooting multiple
images with the mass cam.
And in those images,
of course the master is missing because
it can't photograph the mass camp.
It can't photograph it's own master.
And so you wind up,
you get a great view of the arm,
but the rovers headless and
it's really kind of disturbing.
Is this the one that had to
like really difficult landing?
Like it was really complicated and
they were really worried about it.
Well, if she goes into a lot of detail
about that in a book, by the way, it's,
it's really casting. Yeah.
So, um, it's kind of fun.
It wasn't really complicated landing.
It's a Rube Goldberg he and landing.
So it has,
um,
the problem with landing on Mars is that
it has enough atmosphere to burn you up,
but not enough atmosphere to slow you
down. So it's easier to land on the moon.
It's easier to land on earth,
um, on the moon. No atmosphere.
You just streak in blast with retro
rockets. Boom. You're on the surface.
And the problem on earth parachute and
heat shield slows you down enough where
you just kind of coast into a landing.
That's what the space shuttle's did.
That's what all the Apollo
capsules did on Mars.
You have to combine all of those things.
So you have a heat shield that takes you
from interplanetary travel speeds down
to supersonic speeds.
Then you have a parachute that takes
you from supersonic to subsonic. Um,
then you have rockets that
slow you down from subs,
from subsonic to still.
And then you have to touch down.
And missions have accomplished this
in different ways. Most Mars missions,
our landers and so what the landers
typically do is they get down to it as
opposed to rovers. Yeah, sorry. Um,
so they get pretty close to the surface
and then usually they cut off their
rockets right above the surface because
you don't want to be blasting the
surface with a lot of a rocket exhaust.
And so they'll have like crushable legs.
That's what Phoenix and insight have.
They have legs that can take up that last
bit of drop or you'll have what spirit
and opportunity had,
which are the airbags surrounding
and it actually bounced to a halt,
which I think is nutty.
I mean take a ridiculously expensive
machine and whack it on the surface and
multiple times. That's what spirit and
opportunity in pathline. And so, um,
curiosities approach,
um,
curiosity was already too big to
have any extra lander hardware.
And so it said it had a rocket assisted
backpack that it lowered the rover on a
rope and the rope and then gently let the,
the,
the rover touch the surface
and there slack on the cables.
And once the machine detected
that there slack on the cables,
it cuts the cables and flies a jet pack
away, which like you can just imagine it.
It's just like any Wiley,
Katie, Katie character clunk.
And then there's like a big
explosion and a boom and stuff.
We got a picture of which we actually
got a picture of. It was amazing.
The first curiosity image from the surface
of Mars was taken by its rear has cam
and you see this plume of dust on the
horizon and they later figured out that
that was probably the,
the plume from the explosion of the jet
pack when it crashed on the surface,
which I think is just
great. So yeah, so it was,
it's an incredibly complicated landing.
But as I explained to the book,
it's actually not really out of family
from what had been done before. Um,
hanging the rover on a rope was actually
exactly what they did with spirit and
opportunity.
That airbag thingy was descent,
was hanging on a rope off of
the retro rockets. And so,
um,
the landing looked ridiculous,
but it was very well modeled.
And after they had the, uh,
the two year launch delay, I have never
seen engineers as confident as I saw.
I mean, engineers as a rule are not
confident people, they're like, well,
it might work if all the conditions
are right, love with him. You know,
they don't want to tell you
it's absolutely going to
work because like as they
say in the rocket business, there's a
thousand ways for a lunch to go wrong.
Only one way for it to
go right. And so, um,
but when they were,
uh,
they had the last two years to really
prepare and throw all kinds of um,
situations at it, you
know, dust storms and,
and bad navigation and failure,
one of the rockets and all kinds of stuff.
And the machine in their simulations
perform with flying colors. And in the,
in the final event, it was just straight
down the middle. Everything was nominal,
nominal, nominal. Um,
except for one little detail that maybe
I'll let you guys read the book for.
Yeah.
So software people about while the Mike
is going to the next person and software
people like us, I understand
the concept of, uh, Easter eggs
and little hidden things in, you
know, maybe your web browser,
you hit control alt shift ass and it
pops up a flight simulator or something
like that. Right. Um, and curiosity has
one of those, uh, Easter eggs as well.
And in the wheels before they, before
they had not on purpose holes in them,
they had on purpose holes in them.
That's right. So if you look at
the, the wheels of the rover,
you can see that there are deliberately
a whole bunch of holes punched in them.
Um, this is kind of a callback
to spirit and opportunity,
which they were connected to their lander
with these bolts that were fired and
separated after landing. And so there
are holes on spirit and opportunities.
We all set are there just as an
artifact of the method by which they are
attached to the lander,
but they turned out to be really useful
for the science team because you can see
the little mark that the holes left in
the wheel tracks to actually measure
distances.
Um,
you can also use it to see how much the
rover we will slipped during driving.
So you can kind of measure distances in
one way and then in a different way and
see how long or short it was.
And the rover actually got to
where it was using this for.
Odometry could actually use its own wheel
tracks to help understand how far to
travel.
So they wanted to include some kind
of odometry marking on the wheels on
curiosity to make sure that it would be
easy to tell how many wheel turns there
had been in the rover tracks.
And so the first thing they did was that
they actually machines the letters JPL
into the wheels, into the treads. And
so there's a picture in my book of the,
of the, an early set of wheels that has
JPL on it. So I left tracks JPL, JPL,
JPL as it was going. And that's what I
was like, you guys, you can't do that.
So they came up with another plan,
which was to put the letters
JPL in the wheels in Morse code.
So that's what you see.
There's three rows there and they are,
have like narrower and wider gaps.
And that's the letters JPL in Morse code.
Um,
so this isn't actually a
curiosity question because
there's something else you
mentioned earlier that's been bugging me.
You said the Russians landed
a mostly mechanical, uh,
lander on Venus and electronics wouldn't
stand up to the surface temperatures.
How did they communicate the
information off the planet to us?
Well, um, I don't actually
know enough about the, um,
about how those missions worked. I mean,
they did have like a pressure vessel,
a temperature, um, a safe vessel on
the inside that had the electronic,
the limited electronics that there were,
and they did do radio communications,
director Earth. They didn't have orbiter,
so they were doing it direct to earth.
But then Venus is actually
relatively close to Earth,
so you don't have to have very powerful
radio to get that data back. Um,
I'm afraid I'm not an
electronics person myself,
so I don't really know the
answer to that question.
Um, I, I, we're, we're kind
of, we're starting to run,
I'll run a little low on time.
Um, uh, and it kills me
that we're not going to get,
get to all the questions when I ask you.
Maybe we should take one more audience
question and I'll ask you kind of a wrap
up here.
Okay.
So my question is, uh, what happens
if something mechanical fails?
Is there any self repair kind
of capability? There is not,
but there's a lot of redundancy,
a lot of redundant capability.
So there's a lot of planning done to
figure out how the rover can still
accomplish its mission even if this,
that, or another component fails. Um,
so like the computer
systems are fully redundant.
There's an a side and a B side and
various components or cross strap to each
other. So when a computer
fails as actually happened
200 days into the mission,
they can swap to the backup and operate
on the backup while they repair the
prime computer. And so they've done that
with, um, with the main computer already.
It actually took them a long time
to bring the backup back online,
which was kind of scary.
Um,
there had been mechanical problems like
problems with the wheels. And so, um,
you get through that through robustness,
basically any one of the wheels,
the motors are powerful enough to,
uh, to raise the entire rovers.
Wait vertically.
So like if you attached a rope to it
and you could wind a rope on one of the
wheels and it would,
and the motor is strong enough to
be able to lift the whole rover. Um,
this actually became important for spirit
opportunity because both of them have,
have had different
kinds of wheel failures.
And so spirit in particular was dragging
one of its wheels for a long time. Um,
but the rover is still
able to drive that way.
It's a good thing because we made some
science discoveries because of that. Yeah.
And so, um, the biggest
problem that curiosity has
been dealing with lately is a,
is a major mechanical
failure and the drill,
so the drill used to operate with a
pair of prongs that it pressed against a
rock and then there's a feed mechanism
that pushed the drill into the rock while
the everything else stayed still.
And the feed mechanism failed almost
completely. They, it was very sticky.
They couldn't get it to
move backward and forward,
which is critical for drilling. And so
over the period of more than a year now,
they've managed to get the bulky
feed to extend all the way.
So now the fetus permanently extended
and they just a couple of weeks ago for
the first time,
managed to do what they call feed extended
drilling where instead of using the,
the feed mechanism, which no longer
works there now using arm most motors.
So it's like taking a drill and trying
to drill into a wall like this. You know,
you can imagine it's hard but,
but the curiosity is arm is pretty strong.
And so they just kind of lean on the arm
and they pushed the drill into the rock
and it worked. So, um, it's taken
them a long time to fix it. But, uh,
these engineers are really ingenious
at solving problems. And so,
um, a lot of what you do on an extended
mission and extended extended mission,
which is what curiosity is on now,
is figuring out how to make the most of
an aging machine that does have problems
but can still do great science
where it is. And so, um,
all of these people have a lot
of experience in making, um,
old groany machines work. I mean, I'd
like to write a book about Galileo,
about all the things they had to do to
keep that thing going after radiation
fried at Jupiter multiple times.
And so curiosity is still got a lot of
life in it. Um, they'll have problems. Um,
but you know, they wished
the problems weren't there,
but they, they're like, okay,
here's, this is our new reality and we'll
keep going. That's how it works. So, uh,
it's,
it's killing me that I've got like 20
more questions here and we've got like
three minutes. So that's not
enough time. I'm thinking. Um,
but, uh, but uh, maybe we can end on
this note, uh, by asking you like,
um, what do you hope that readers
will take away from this gorgeous,
terrific book that I could
not more highly recommend?
Oh Gosh. I hope that they will. Um,
I guess I hope that people will take away
the fact that they can understand this
is a very complicated machine,
but what it's doing,
why it's there and how it works or not,
or not inaccessible to everyone.
And that's one of the great things about
space exploration I think is that it's
easy to explain why we're doing it.
The fundamental questions we're trying
to answer. Was there ever a life on Mars?
Are we alone in the universe?
That kind of stuff. Um, and it's,
and it's fairly easy to understand how
we're going about solving those problems.
Were sending a robot with a drill that's
like sampling rocks and we put them
into a lab and, and all of these things.
And you can communicate with children.
You can communicate with
science interested in adults
as well. Um, and it's,
it's just very accessible and,
um,
everybody can kind of participate in the
adventure by following along with what
they're doing.
They,
they share their raw images straight from
ours directly on the Internet so that
you can see every day, you can tune in at
JPL and see what they've been doing. Um,
I highly recommend
midnight planets.com as a,
it's a,
um,
an enthusiast built website
that aggregates all of the
images from the different
rovers and puts them up in ways that are
easy to see. And it's, uh, it's just,
it's a fun adventure and we're
all part of it, basically. Yeah.
Emily, I'm so sad that we're at
a time. Um, uh, uh, but I, I,
I enthusiastically recommend this book.
The book is the design and
engineering of curiosity,
how the Mars rover performs its job.
All the stuff you've heard us talk about
today at a whole lot more stuff is in
there. It's really terrific.
I highly recommend it. Yeah.
It's also on my blog at planetary.org/blog
you'll find I write updates about
every two or three months
on what curiosity is doing.
I'll probably have a new one
out in a couple of weeks,
right on. Um, I wish we
had another hour to talk,
but maybe you'll be able to come
back and we'll be able to do it then.
In the meantime, please join
me in thanking our guest
today. Emily Lakdawalla.